fang shiu is a student in the world's
toughest shaolin school in the opening
scene he gets ready for the final test
that will determine if he is worthy of
graduating as a prestigious warrior the
test is known as the wooden death battle
in the test shiyu has to fight wooden
puppets controlled by many great
warriors who have trained for several
decades only a few percent of students
pass this test but shiu is confident in
his skills as soon as he tells the
puppets that he is ready they start to
move the first attack is made by a pair
but it is an easy dodge but then a third
puppet hits him in the chest revealing
the first two moves were just a
distraction she used stomps on the
ground and his robe flies off his torso
his skin starts to glow forming a
protective layer of copper around his
body it is the most advanced technique
called the copper skin that shiu had
mastered at a young age following that
he defeats all the puppets one after
another just when he thinks he is done
the puppets combine and transform into a
bigger version of themselves this
structure is not as easy to defeat as
the previous ones when she realizes that
he cannot beat it with strength he
decides to use his brain instead he
looks for a chance to get his hands on
the strings being used to control the
puppet then he pulls on them causing the
handlers to fall was that a strategy or
was that just cheating in the end he
defeats the uncontrolled puppet and
graduates with honor in the following
scene we are introduced to a corrupt
elected official named lao recently he
stole 5 million yuan from the city's
treasury for personal gain it is the
biggest fraud the city has ever faced
and lao is eager to hide his involvement
in the heist hence he kills his
accomplice and his entire family with
the help of his right-hand man ming lau
doesn't want to spare even the ones
looking for him just to ensure the truth
never comes out however a ledger made by
his assistant that has all the details
about the money has been stolen he has
to get it back before it gets into the
hands of the great emperor if his
involvement is proven he is sure to be
executed somewhere else shiu arrives in
his hometown and meets his childhood
best friend han they decide to not tell
his mother about his arrival because she
is strict and won't let them have fun
they are also friends with a girl named
wrong she is in love with shiu while han
is in love with her so the best friends
have a love triangle going on between
them han and shiu are on their way to
meet her when they come across a giant
beast of a man hurting a guy smaller
than him the giant is named bearpaw and
is working for the corrupt lao shiyu
interrupts them and attacks paw the
other guy runs away while paw and shiu
fight soon paw realizes that his
opponent is a warrior but the guy he
wanted has already run away so he
doesn't see any use in fighting he also
runs away on a horse while being
followed by shiyu they stop in the
middle of the market and are about to go
for a second round but xiu's mother who
is also a trained fighter interrupts the
commotion this gives paw a chance to
escape and shiu is caught he lied to his
mother that he wouldn't be in the city
for two more days knowing that he was
planning to create more trouble she puts
him under house arrest but she was not
someone who can be controlled so easily
he makes sure his mother is not in the
house before running outside to get his
clothes just then he comes across a
beautiful girl named tang since she is
changing her clothes she screams on
seeing a man in front of her before she
can ask him who he is she notices a
group of soldiers coming her way she
quickly hides leaving shiu to talk to
the soldiers they inquire if he has seen
a girl nearby but she who helps ting and
sends them away with the wrong
information just when tang comes out and
thanks him han and wrong arrive at the
scene wrong thinks something is going on
between them and is filled with jealousy
she runs away and to clear the
misunderstanding shiyu pulls ting behind
and follows her in the market a man
shows han a sketch asking him if he has
seen the person han recognizes the
sketch as wrong's father but doesn't
tell that to the stranger he also
registers that the stranger works for a
wealthy businessman named tiger which
might mean tiger is after wrong's father
he immediately goes to wrong and tells
her what he saw she thanks him for
informing her but is unfazed because her
father is in another town although wrong
pretends like everything is fine in
front of han as soon as he leaves her
demeanor changes she brings out a chest
that contains the ledger that the
corrupt official lao is looking for
wrong's father is the original bearer of
the ledger and has the power to end
lao's rule this is why many soldiers are
behind him and his daughter the next
morning she and ting come to wrong's
home to clear up the misunderstanding
however they find han frantically
running out of the house it turns out
that wrong is missing and han thinks the
businessman tiger has kidnapped her
since he was looking for her father
yesterday shiu doesn't waste time before
looking for tiger the man is in the
market fighting people in a challenge
the crowd battle shiu goes to the stage
asking him where wrong is but even tiger
has no clue what he is talking about
they get into a fight and shiu easily
defeats him to his surprise tiger laughs
and accepts his defeat declaring him his
son-in-law it is then revealed that the
challenge the crowd was a quest to look
for a husband for his daughter tiger
really doesn't seem to know anything
about wrong's disappearance so she who
lets him go he also runs away from the
crowd hoping he won't be forced to marry
someone he doesn't like in the following
scene everyone is in rong's house when
she walks in revealing that she was
never kidnapped they asked her where she
was but rong doesn't want to answer the
question just yet she hands shiu a
sculpture of him that she made herself
han feels jealous but doesn't show it on
his face later shiu and ting are on
their way back home when all of a sudden
tiger's people surround them tiger asks
ting where she has been for the past
three days only then does xiu figure out
that tiger's daughter who he is supposed
to marry is none other than tang tiger
also discloses that he is only looking
for wrong's father because he was asked
to do so by the court it was a direct
order from officer lau so he could not
decline shiyu puts two and two together
and registers that wrong is in trouble
he is too late to realize this because
somewhere else the right-hand man ming
has already found wrong and her father
he is holding both of them hostage until
they reveal where the ledger is rong's
father repeatedly refuses to say
anything making ming impatient as a
result he threatens to kill wrong to
everyone's surprise her father commits
the unthinkable so she won't get hurt
because of him right then shiu arrives
and sees that he is late the guards try
to attack him but he kicks them all away
and even lands a strong punch on ming's
chest knowing that they cannot fight
their way through him ming takes wrong
hostage and escapes with his people in
the end shiu is left helpless with
wrong's father's dead body meanwhile lao
finds out the mission was unsuccessful
he orders paw and his father who to kill
shiu and bring the ledger to him at all
costs pod isn't like his father kneeling
down in front of someone as evil as lao
but he does is told for whose sake
somewhere else she receives a letter
calling him eastwood with the ledger in
turn for wrong's life he meets ming who
and paw at the location later at night
to everyone's surprise he gives them the
ledger without a fuss but ming soon
finds out it is a fake this gives rise
to a battle between paw and shiyu they
match in strength until who throws a
poisonous powder into shih's face which
makes him weak paw is ordered to take
the opportunity and kill the man
immediately but he is busy helping his
old and injured father after the father
and son leave ming plans to end shiyu on
his own but right then tiger arrives and
saves his life in the end ming and his
remaining soldiers have to retreat at
home she soaks in a herbal bath to get
rid of the effects of the poison
meanwhile ming gives paw the last chance
to save his life after what he did the
last night he is bound to be killed but
in turn for his life he is asked to kill
shiyu and prove his worth paw goes to
plan a move leaving his father with ming
ming suggests who'd do something to not
let his son be distracted again who says
he understands and decides to make a
huge decision at this instant in the
meantime shiyu is looking at the
sculpture that wrong gifted him he
accidentally presses a button and
discovers the ledger is inside it now he
can finally get wrong back but that
would mean lao gets away with corruption
just then shiu gets a letter from paw
and leaves without telling anyone where
he is going a while later he and paul
meet in a field and attack each other
pau's life is at risk so he gives it all
but she who again overpowers him in the
end he is about to land a deadly punch
on his face but decides otherwise she
remembers that paw had a chance to kill
him yesterday but he didn't since he
spared his life today they are even
following the fight paw goes home and
finds who lying unconscious with a
poison pot in his hand he has committed
the unthinkable because of ming's wish
to punish someone in the following scene
han arrives at lao's residence and
demands he let ron go he has even
brought the ledger to trade her life
with wrong is brought outside with
injuries all over her body it is clear
that she was tortured while imprisoned
han is about to hand over the ledger
when shiu arrives and pushes ming back
he is joined by tiger and his mother who
fight lao's people while he is busy
fighting the main villain for the first
time in his life shiyu faces an opponent
stronger than himself his copper
protective layer is broken by lao who
has bones made of iron she who is only
seconds away from being killed when rong
comes to his defense and takes the knife
herself she dies in the incident and an
enraged han runs to take revenge but
against the wrath of mighty lao he is
also killed at the same time tiger and
shiyu's mother are held captive lao
turns his attention towards shiyu again
but this time he is stopped by paw he is
furious at lao for killing his father
taking this opportunity she runs away to
save the ledger and himself at last lau
kills paw as well a day later a notice
about criminals execution is put out lau
has falsely accused tiger and xiu's
mother and is about to hang them to
death now only their trump card the
ledger can save their life on the day of
the execution a small crowd gathers to
witness it shiyu interrupts the ceremony
and declares lao is a fraud in front of
everyone he even lists the illegal
things lao has done in the past the
audience starts chanting to abolish him
which angers lao even more he sends his
army to attack the crowd but half of
them are not civilians but actually
tigers workers they get into a fierce
battle with the opponent tiger and xiu's
mother fight ming while shiyu takes care
of lao in a nearby shed he is more
confident in his moves but still lao
matches his energy the fight only turns
to shiyu's side when lao is hit by a
swinging log he vomits blood and is
finally defeated outside all of lao's
people have lost following that the
emperor shang comes to the arena he is
shown the ledger which proves lao's
involvement in corruption and at last he
is imprisoned the movie ends as the
emperor jokes that tiger can lend him
some money for the treasury tiger laughs
and agrees
subscribe for more videos like this turn
on notifications and leave a like to
help the channel out thank you for
watching